WIL WILLIS: Allen.
Clayton.
Congratulations, you both made
it through to the final round.
When you showed
up at this forge,
you used our tools and
equipment to forge signature
blades in your own style.
Now we're sending you
back to your home forge,
where you will have
five days to forge
an iconic weapon from history.
The boar spear.
WIL WILLIS (VOICEOVER):
Developed as early as 700 AD
in Europe, the boar
spear was forged
for both combat and hunting.
Known at the time
as a "bar spare,"
the weapon was about
five to six feet long,
and featured a pair of lugs
below the leaf-shaped blade.
When hunting, the lugs
would stop a speared boar
from running up the
length of the weapon,
and attacking the user.
In combat, the lugs
could be used to hook
and pull away enemy shields.
The blade of the spear
could be decorated,
with some featuring finely
engraved scenes of hunts.
On the first season
of "Game of Thrones,"
King Robert Baratheon
carried a boar
spear on his final boar hunt.
WIL WILLIS: Good
luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in five days.
Good luck.
CLAYTON: Day two.
I really need to figure
out the design of the lugs.
Boars are pretty strong
animals, so if they don't have
a wide enough
cross section, they
could just end up running that
through their body themselves.
One of the ways I could do it
is cutting a section of the pipe
out, and bending it out.
It's going to take
a lot of work,
but it's something
that needs to be done.
I'm battling the
clock on this one.
I've decided to put my lugs
perpendicular to my blade.
It just made more sense to
have them perpendicular,
to stop the spear
from over-penetrating.
It should work.
ALLEN: It's day three.
Time's really crunched.
I'm just really
behind the eight ball.
Getting the lugs
on the spear shaft.
Oh man.
I believe my blower
has just died.
My forge burnt out,
the engine died.
Now I'm going to have
to find a replacement.
There's still a lot to do.
I am literally running to the
store to buy another blower.
Things just really are
not going my way today.
My forge burnt out,
the engine died.
Had to run out and lose time.
I had to get a new motor.
With all these setbacks, I'm
starting to be a bit worried.
All right, it works.
With the way things
have been going today,
we're coming down to
the wire on time here.
It could come back to bite me.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Bladesmiths.
This is the sharpness test.
To see how sharp
your boar spears are,
we will test the
tip and the edge
by stabbing and slashing
through these sandbags.
All right.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Clayton,
you're up first.
You ready?
- I'm ready.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Well, Clayton.
The balance of your tip
lends itself to stabbing.
Your edge lacerated cleanly
on the moving sandbag.
What surprised me was the
positioning of your lug.
Traditionally, they have
it crosswise this way.
But you have it this way.
Because of that, it
was hard to index
when you're cutting through.
But then again, it will cut.
Thank you
Allen, you're next.
Ready?
Oh yeah.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Well, Allen.
Your spear feels
good to hold on to.
It was easy to index in
the way the edge was.
So that was a nice slash
and I can penetrate through.
And in the thrust, it
felt good in the hand.
All right.
I can see a little
bow in your handle.
But when we're talking
about the sharpness test,
this, sir, will cut.
All right.
Next stop is a kill test.
To see what kind of lethal
damage your weapon can do,
I will deliver lethal blows
to this wild boar carcass.
Clayton, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Absolutely.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Well, Clayton.
Your boar spear right here
did very well on the thrust,
penetrating all the way
through, on the low line,
and on the high line.
On the edge, you
lacerated cleanly
and testing the
other side, it cut
all the way through the spine.
This sir, will kill.
Good job.
Thank you.
Allen, you're next.
You ready?
Oh yeah.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Let's do this.
Well, Allen, let's
talk about your blade.
On the thrust, it penetrated
all the way through.
On the laceration, on one
side of your edge, boy, wow.
It almost sliced
all the way through.
On your other edge, it
lacerated through the spine.
This piercer will kill.
All right.
DAVID BAKER:
Gentlemen, it's been
said that the sword is
the prince of all weapons,
but the spear is the king.
To test the strength
of your boar spears,
I'm gonna load them
into our air cannon
here, and fire them
into this wooden target.
Oh my.
We'll see how
deep it penetrates,
how well it holds up, and if
it holds up while I remove
the spear from the target.
Awesome.
Clayton, you're up first.
You ready?
I am.
DAVID BAKER: In three, two, one.
Whew.
Well, Clayton, your
spear really dug in deep.
It went in about four inches.
Came out fine.
Everything still
tight and dialed in.
This is interesting,
being offset.
Being that it's
a boar spear, I
wanted to make sure
that whatever laceration
the blade produced
on the animal,
wasn't wide enough to allow
the wings to come through.
And the best way
to do that was just
to make them perpendicular.
All right.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
DAVID BAKER: Allen, you're up.
A little warp in your shaft.
I'm picking it up
in the tube there,
so hopefully it
will all fly well.
All right in three, two, one.
All right, Allen, that
buried itself quite nicely.
Went in to about there,
again, about four inches deep.
Like the leaf shape on this.
I like the fact that you
hand-hammered to the socket.
I was kind of worried when
I put this in our machine,
that slight warp in your
shaft there would bind up.
But not a problem.
Good job.
Thank you.
WIL WILLIS: Bladesmiths.
Both of you have turned
in fantastic boar spears.
However in this
arena of competition,
there can only be one
Forged in Fire champion.
Allen.
Congratulations, you are
the Forged in Fire champion.
CLAYTON: Congratulations.
ALLEN: You did awesome.
WIL WILLIS: Clayton.
Please surrender your weapon.
CLAYTON: Right now, I guess I
am a little bit disappointed.
But this is the
first spear I made.
And for me, it's
really important
that it was such a tight race.
I don't want it to be
anything that I handed him,
or anything that he
would have handed me.
Allen is a deserving champion.
WIL WILLIS: Allen,
congratulations.
You are the Forged
in Fire champion
and with that comes
a check for $10,000.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
DAVID BAKER: You know what I
really appreciate about that,
is the fact that you
took the time to actually
hammer that cone out.
Making that socket is a
really nice touch on any kind
of traditional spear.
It's well done.
I am the Forged
in Fire champion.
I cannot believe it.
I had no idea if it was going
to be me or him, and it was me.
I'm betting being a
Forged in Fire champion
is going to help
this stay-at-home dad
slash knife maker, convince
a few people that they
should try out my blades.
That's great.